I'm gonna show you something beautiful
everyone sleeping for mercy won't
protect the world but you don't want it
to change
you're all puppets tangled in strings
strings
it's the end the end of the path I
started us on nothing lasts forever
there are no strings on
hey youtubers is Charlie so the age of
Ultron trailer totally leads last night
obviously everyone has pretty much seen
it Marvel did the only logical thing and
officially released it on their channel
so it's totally clear for me to post now
so this will be a breakdown of the
trailer which is basically an expanded
version of the comic-con trailer and an
explanation of how this is going to lead
into Captain America 3 in the Civil War
storyline that everyone's been talking
about so starting off we just see a
regular cityscape this is obviously
before
Ultron goes crazy on everyone and here
the fun starts so this is basically just
a repeat of what we saw in the first
Avengers movie everything goes crazy The
Avengers are called in to help this
melting affect this hand here is
obviously Ultron forging himself a new
body one of the really cool things that
Joss Whedon said that he would be
honoring is the fact that Ultron gets
better he evolves himself during San
Diego comic-con they even showed off
Ultron mark 1 it just looks like a
modified Iron Man suit obviously the
final version of Ultron looks way way
scarier much cooler too in the comics
Ultron eventually forges himself an
adamantium body it just basically
presence make himself as indestructible
as possible here we start to see The
Avengers looking like they're getting
the crap beat out of them just like New
York all over again
Captain America obviously wearing his
shiny new suit this one actually looks
way way better it's basically a riff on
the classic suit which obviously put on
a Winter Soldier Hawkeye who was notably
cut out of Winter Soldier he actually
did have a cameo in that movie and they
just they cut his part out because the
movie was so long supposedly Jeremy
Renner said that he's up for a solo
movie but that doesn't mean that they're
gonna do it anytime soon
Thor here is actually in this movie
living on earth they'll explain the
drama that's going on in Asgard and
where Onan is and what's going on with
Loki during the third Thor movie that's
going to be in phase 3 it's one of the
confirmed phase 3 movies here's a pretty
pornographic shot of the quintet it just
looks totally badass this is clearly
after a big battle if you haven't read
the comic age of Ultron it's different
from what the movie is going to be it's
not the same plot but it basically shows
the Avengers getting their asses handed
to them so we zoom in on Mark Ruffalo
and he actually said some interesting
things about what's going on with the
Hulk in this movie he said that they
addressed the fact that the green guy is
just as afraid of banner as banner is of
the green guy which is a really
interesting idea that
idea that the Hulk is afraid of Bruce
Banner you can almost think of this as
like a minor Hulk movie this is an
Ultron mark 1 this is more like mark 2
but he busts in on an Avengers party
this is basically part of the comic-con
footage they showed off this right here
though this is part of Ultron mark 1 see
it basically looks like a modified stark
suit Tony Stark basically plugs his
modified AI into one of his suits and
it's not Jarvis even though the vision
is basically where Jarvis comes from
modified Jarvis that is it's not
straight up Jarvis it's something a
little bit different very interesting
obviously we're not going to see that in
the first trailer this is basically the
moment where Ultron turns against them
though and comes to the realization that
humanity needs to be wiped out the funny
thing is that like a lot of robots like
Cylons for instance Ultron is really
true to his programming he's programmed
to make the world a better place but he
determines the humans are a cancer on
the earth and so humans need to go
here's the new Iron Man suit looks
totally badass obviously looks like a
modified version of the Ultron Mark one
suit that we just saw this is one of
Baron von strucker's labs since Winter
Soldier the Avengers have been traveling
all over the world trying to clean up
all these Hydra bases that's why they
create Ultron because there's too many
of them for them to all get even with
all their powers I know everyone's
wondering whether or not the mind gem is
in Loki's staff which Baron von Strucker
has that hasn't been confirmed it's just
the best rumor so far so here we get
some conflict all over the world so what
happens is he basically splits the
Avengers focus all over the world so
it's not one attack in one place and her
freaking out in the woods it wouldn't be
an Avengers movie if it weren't banner
freaking out somewhere this is Black
Widow in the ruins of shield if you
remember this is actually one of the
rooms that they were in during Winter
Soldier we don't see who this is
obviously it looks very sinister so I'm
guessing it's one of the villains Andy
Serkis
is actually in the movie we don't know
who he's playing so it might be
associated with that or might be a Baron
von Strucker scene here's Ultron in his
final form in all his glory the fact
that Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch or
standing near him says a lot
they're obviously like the next step in
human evolution so that's a big point of
contention especially with the Civil War
idea on the horizon a lot of people are
speculating that the age of miracles so
to speak is what inspires the civil war
conflict like the idea that people need
to read
stur their powers just because they
start getting so crazy here's some of
the Ultron robots these the ones he's
gonna be sending all over the earth
here's another shot of Ultron mark 1
this is actually the prop that they
brought to comic-con it was really cool
it was literally this prop you're
looking at right here Nick Fury back in
action totally awesome to see Sam
Jackson remember after Winter Soldier he
basically went off the grid just to hunt
Hydra people down obviously Scarlet
Witch screaming here is a bit of an
easter egg for no more mutants in the
House of M that's not really what the
movie is doing they're not gonna do
House of M type stuff her powers don't
work exactly that way and the Hulkbuster
so this is actually gonna be really
awesome I know everybody was waiting for
this Hulk vs the Avengers is going to be
too crazy in this movie the funny thing
that Joss Whedon said about the
Hulkbuster armor though is that it came
after he stopped reading the comics like
he's a big comic book fan of course he
always has been it's just that the
Hulkbuster armor appeared in the comics
after he had started working at
Hollywood so he just didn't have the
time to keep up every week this is black
widows new motorcycle it is one of the
most badass motorcycles you've ever seen
here's actually a better shot of it I
just love the idea that she drops out of
a movie in quintet here we get some nice
shots of Quicksilver and Scarlet witch's
powers and here he is Andy Serkis
we don't really know anything about his
villain other than he is a villain like
he is definitely a very bad person in
this movie so this is actually a really
interesting scene
Black Widow with banner as the Hulk
there's a lot of rumors that he's going
to have some sort of implied
relationship with her in the movie they
have some sort of ship going but they
haven't consummated their relationship
because banner is afraid of going Hulk
mid sex you can choose whether or not to
believe that it's just a rumor right now
but supposedly Black Widow will be
having some sort of romance with Bruce
Banner and here's the conflict so
obviously everyone's talking about civil
war that means the Avengers have to
start fighting this really does support
that idea Thor is probably just choking
Tony Stark out because of what happens
with Ultron like it's probably right
after Ultron rebels of course he's the
AI genius so everyone's totally gonna
blame him here's some more Hulk Buster
porn totally awesome I'm going to
rewatch that three or four thousand
times and here's the big WTF this was
actually in the Comic Con trailer
Captain America shield is broken so in
the movie universe they call it
vibranium obviously in the comics is
adamantium but the x-men you
verse fox writes you know yadda yadda
yadda essentially this is the hardest
metal on earth so that's why this is
such a big deal the reason this is
broken is because Ultron forges a new
body for himself out of that same metal
and here he is
so when Ultron is talking about strings
in this trailer he's talking about
obviously control like Tony Stark
controlling him like a puppet which
isn't happening anymore and he's talking
about the strings that connect people
emotionally so he's a robot
he doesn't feel emotion we didn't called
him something of an insane robot so I do
kind of wonder if he develops a certain
personality maybe not emotion definitely
personality so really what this trailer
does is just take us up to like the oh
[ __ ] moment like Ultron strikes and
starts crushing everyone everything's in
chaos during comic-con the way the movie
was explained is that a lot of this is
about the good and the bad child of Tony
Stark
obviously the bad child being Ultron the
good child being the vision we've
already seen a bit of a teaser form in
this promo art here this is what he
looks like obviously you know he's gonna
look a little bit different in CG just a
little bit better that is Paul Bettany
will be playing him in full-on mocap so
he will move like a human obviously as
well ultron like this is what Ultron
looks like behind the scenes when
they're filming
James Spader actually made some jokes
about trying to play an 8 foot tall
robot versus a human it's always funny
to watch interviews with really amazing
actors that don't normally do John
restof like this they always had this
really funny fresh perspective on it
like it's all very weird and awesome to
them like playing in someone else's
sandbox so just explain the civil war
stuff that's going on obviously after
this movie it's implied that the
Avengers are going to be fractured
they're going to go their separate ways
Thor is going to go back to Asgard and
that'll be where Thor 3 picks up Captain
America is going to go his own way
that's where Captain America 3 picks up
I have heard a lot of West Coast
Avengers rumors obviously that's where
Captain America forms his own Avengers
team and it becomes West Coast Avengers
the rumor is is the Captain America 3 is
going to feature Secret Avengers they're
just going to do something like that
basically Captain America with his own
team of heroes away from Tony Stark but
because all these new people start
manifesting powers like Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch supposedly the government
gets involved because this becomes such
a global problem Tony Stark takes their
side naturally being a government
contractor and you have civil war
if you haven't read the comics totally
check it out it's an awesome storyline
it's possible they could just like bleed
that over and Avengers 3 but the rumors
that Avengers 3 is going to be a
complete BTW movie like it won't feature
the a-list main Avengers so yes the
Marvel verse is going to be thrown into
complete chaos but it's going to be a
lot of fun
obviously they just want to expand
things so they don't need to rely on
their a players quite as much I think
it's a good way to ensure that everyone
doesn't start suffering from Avengers
fatigue and it gives the potential
directors obviously the Russo brothers
who are probably gonna be taking over
Avengers 3 some fresh faces to work with
like I said it's all good thing now that
we've seen this in all its glory they're
going to start posting more updates so I
will be doing more Avengers videos as we
go forward be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you have any special
requests for bonus videos let me know my
next Avengers video is going to be my
top 5 Ultron stories so I'll try to post
that tomorrow right now you can click
here to get that and you can click here
to learn all about the Captain America 3
Civil War drama
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five and re-watch that trailer
you